2017 was an amazing year for CS:GO from
Gambits incredible run at the Krakow
Major to SK's returned to the very top
of counter-strike so to celebrate the
best player storylines this year we put
together a list of the top 10
Kicking off our list at number 10 is swag
now swags 2017 was not very eventful
but for swag one of the most famous
players permanently banned by Valve 2017
brought an important change
(Casting)
this summer ESL and DreamHack announced
they would unbanned swag and other
former IBUYPOWER players from their
events the move gave his fans some hope
that they may see the CS prodigy on some
of the biggest stages in the game once
again despite still being banned by
Valve and that CS_summit swag showed us
that he still has what it takes to
compete with the best in the world
oh shut up swag
number 9 on our list
gob b the in-game leader for BIG had an
unexpectedly strong year placing 2nd at
two DreamHacks and winning the minor
championship for the Krakow of major but
perhaps most unexpectedly god b took an
underrated roster of misfits to legend
status at the major when they made it to quarterfinals
(Casting)
there was some controversy
surrounding BIG at the major when they
utilize the jump bug during the group
stage that allowed invisible and
soundless speaking on some maps but
after a gentlemen's agreement between
teams to not use the bug BIG still
defeated SK 2 3-0 the group stage
(Casting)
they fell
in the top eight gob b and BIG have
guaranteed themselves a spot at the next
major in Boston and we're excited to see
what 2018 could bring for them
(Casting)
olofmeister comes in at
number eight on our list once widely
regarded as the best player in the world
Olaf joined FaZe in August after a
somewhat lackluster end to his time with
Fnatic
it is like starting over again and that's something that I guess Ineeded I get this feeling of a little
bit nervous again and that's something I
have been missing I just want to play
since joining FaZe Olaf has proven he's
still one of the best helping the team
when ESL One New York and the ELEAGUE
premier also placing second at IEM
Oakland Faze still have a lot to prove
if they want to live up to their
potential but all eyes will be on this
team and olofmeister heading into the Boston Major
he secures around single-handedly and
the legend returns it shows us what he's
made of that should be a closer a Mike
at this Frank but not meant to be what
an epic performance of Olaf
GeT_RiGhT has not had a good year but he ended the
year with a redemption story and that's
why he is number 7 on our list after
missing out on their third consecutive
major by falling in the online
qualifiers for Boston in October
GeT_RiGhT was heartbroken
And Rez will fall
Pride upset NIP and won't be
going to the EU miner saying there is
Saying, "There is nothing more to say then this is
soul-crushing don't really have any words
but his play at IEM
Oakland in November showed that the
organization that first dominated CS:GO
still has a bit of fight left in the team
and GeT_RiGhT closes it
A best- of- five
against the best in the world
and NIP go back-to-back in Oakland
number six on our list is electronic
long seen as a bright star on a
struggling FlipSid3 Tactics Electronic
finally got his big break this year
an electronic left it's right side drink
electronic what are you doing there's a
quad kill for electronic who even
finishes up the job
what are nuts play from electronic
joining a Na'Vi roster that has a lot of
potential with Na'Vi electronic place
12th at season six of Pro League and one
DreamHack Winter
Na'Vi has not quite lived up to the hype
surrounding their roster but their win
at Dreamhack winter represented signs of
life for the squad and electronic may
have finally found a team where he can
really shine
electronic is exploding in
this round and Na'Vi could be on the
brink of a victory now it's all down to
Niko he's been spotted in electronic
he's not gonna get the ACE but Eddie
takes it away it doesn't matter in the end
playing with two Brazilian squads in
2017 boltz comes in at number five on
our list with the Immortals he placed
third to fourth at the IEM World
Championship in Katowice and second at
the Krakow Major but big results aside
boltz story this year revolves around
the roster shake ups after Immortals
Brazilian CS:GO team effectively
dissolved despite their strong performances
first it's no secret to
anyone that follows CS:GO that our roster
has been undergoing some difficulties
over the last few months
with many ex-Immortals players joining new teams
boltz was the most successful of his
former teammates in the latter half of
2017 returning to his former Luminosity
gaming teammates on SK with SK boltz one
EPICENTER and BLAST Pro Series
Copenhagen and placed third to fourth at
IEM Oakland for fans of the Brazilian
scene boltz returned to Fallen and the
rest of SK was thrilling
but equally thrilling was his
performance
what a comeback from 12- 3 in
the first half these rounds are so
incredibly close Fallen and just barely
stops the ball play before he goes down
boltz on a 1 on 3 gets a kill
coming in at number 4 on our list
Zeus rose to the highest highs of
Counter-Strike in 2017
he won the Krakow
of major with Gambit and
had somewhat more measured results with
Na'vi though he did win Dreamhack winter 2017
Navi are your champions in an exquisite
2-0 performance and throughout this
entire event
but for Zeus the winning Krakow was the
culmination of a year-long promise to himself
you tweeted I will not give up
till a win a mother ** Major
you just did that
now what are you gonna do
I just say, olofmiester I love you
and second god help me and I won Major
Zeus' leadership on Gambit was central
to their victory at the Major
and though he has since returned to Na'Vi to
somewhat mixed results his win with
Gambit at Krakow after his colorful
declaration almost a year earlier helped
to define his 2017
Gambit have done it
along with an always
strong SK Gaming fer had a very strong 2017
placing second at DreamHack masters
and then winning IEM Sydney ECS season 3
ESL one Cologne EPICENTER and BLAST Pro
series Copenhagen
they had a somewhat weaker showing at the majors this year placing top four at ELEAGUE and top
eight at Krakow
fer has always been an
excellent player on an excellent team
but in 2017 he really cemented himself
as one of the core stars that made this
SK roster so successful
(Casting)
with SK looking
to make a splash at the ELEAGUE major
in Boston 2018 there's no question that
fer will be front and center
(Casting)
number 2 on our list dev1ce had a 2017 that saw him in peak form winning the ELEAGUE major and the IEM
World Championship in Katowice he also
placed a four at Krakow
but what should have been the landmark year for the
prodigal AWPer talk a sour note when he
was forced to take a break due to
medical issues with Astralis playing a
series of stand-ins dev1ce has had to
take a back seat at the end of 2017
though he is confirmed he'll be playing
in the next major it's not clear what
his health will permit
(Casting)
it's a bitter end of the year for one of
the game's strongest players we can only
hope he'll be back in full force in 2018
dev1ce with 2 in 1 round that's insane
and he's gonna get the defuse on
the back of it as well that is absolute pandemonium
surprising no one NiKo
rounds out our list at number one
starting the season off with a
struggling mousesports NiKo placed 12th
to 14th at the e league major an after
joining FaZe Clan they also struggled at
the Krakow of major placing 15th to 16th
but a late season resurgence saw them
finish 1st at ESL one New York and the ELEAGUE premier second at IEM Auckland
and third at blast Pro Series Copenhagen
NiKo's 2017 saw the realization of his
enormous potential long scene as the
primary carry on the former mouz roster
(Casting)
though the new FaZe Clan took some
time to gel they look like one of the
strongest teams in the world
and NiKo's
play has been a huge part
(Casting)